- [Voiceover] Both mitosis and meiosis
are forms of cell division
that produce daughter cells
containing genetic information
from the parent cell.
Part a.
Describe two events that are common
to both mitosis and meiosis
that ensure the resulting daughter cells
inherit the appropriate
number of chromosomes.
All right.
So, really we just wanna,
well, what are two
commonalities between the two?
Well, I can think of a bunch of them.
You could start off saying,
well, DNA replicates before
going into either of them.
So DNA replicates
before either,
before either.
You could say,
well, the chromatin
condenses into chromosomes
in both of them.
Chromatin, chromatin
condenses,
condenses into,
into chromosomes.
You could talk about chromosomes form,
getting aligned near
the center of the cell,
attaching to, to, to fibers.
You could talk about,
we could talk about cytokinesis.
Splitting the cells.
So, cytokinesis,
kinesis involved,
involved in creation of separate cells.
Creation of separate,
separate cells.
In general the,
your meiosis one has a lot of analogs
with mitosis in general.
You could keep looking,
keep digging deeper and
listing more and more.
They just want me to describe two events.
I've already described three.
Well, I'll leave it at that for now.
In general, before you take the AP test,
mitosis and meiosis are good
things to know in detail,
because you might see questions like this
on the free answer section,
or they're likely to show up
in the multiple choice section as well.
But I think this is sufficient for part a.
We've described at least two events
that are common to both
mitosis and meiosis.
If you have extra time,
you might try to list more.
And then part b.
The genetic composition of daughter cells
produced by mitosis differs
from that of the daughter
cells produced by meiosis.
Describe two features of
the cell division process
that lead to these differences.
Well, maybe the most obvious one,
the biggest difference between them,
is mitosis,
mitosis involves one division,
involves one division.
Meiosis involves two.
Meiosis involves,
involves, not inolves,
involves, involves two.
This leads to
two daughter cells
from mitosis,
and four daughter,
daughter cells
from meiosis.
Meiosis.
That's a pretty big difference
between the two.
Another big difference,
and this is related to this.
Because,
because meiosis
has an extra division,
has extra
division,
but DNA
replicates once,
like in, once,
like in mitosis,
the daughter cells from meiosis
have half the number of chromosomes.
They have a haploid number of chromosomes.
The daughter
cells
in meiosis
have a haploid
number of chromosomes,
number of
chromosomes.
Chromosomes.
So, and we could say,
mitosis daughters have diploid,
daughters have diploid number.
And these are probably the
two strongest differences.
But you could talk about other things.
You could talk about crossing
over occurring in meiosis
but not in mitosis.
You could talk about the separation
and independent sortment
of homologous chromosomes that you have.
Homologous, each member
of a homologous pair
that you have in meiosis
that you don't have in mitosis.
So there's a bunch of
things you could talk about.
And you could go into arbitrary detail.
It's nice that they only have
to list two in each of these,
in each of these parts of question four.